[Music]
foreign
people together you know
but there's lots of uh Mr Rogers I you
know what it is I grew up with Mr Rogers
like a little kid but in high school I
rediscovered him before school when I'd
like eat my cereal I would watch Mr
Rogers and I I just took him in in a
completely different way with a with a
more developed brain where I go like
this is
beautiful like I mean I honestly watch
an episode of Mr Rogers you're gonna cry
how's it what was it like when you when
you saw when you were older because he
caring for children and that he believed
that adults all adults I have no
children but there are children in my
life and and
that our real job as adults is helping
children through all the changes of life
you know and I just think it's beautiful
you know I mean honestly please watch
Google Mr Rogers uh in the at the Senate
on the senate floor space yes I saw and
did you see did you like the movie or
did you see the movie and the
documentary yes yeah the documentary we
um I was working on this Hulu show I
love you America and we went as a field
trip and then um the movie I was sobbing
and I met his wife was there and it was
Ginny and it was not cool like I was too
much of a mess and it was I think she
was uncomfortable I was like I just you
know it was really I you know I'm not a
big crier because I I'm on Zoloft but I
like I was just so moved I just I'm so
moved by it's this is
hardcore but like it's crazy he wasn't
discovered to be a pedophile or
something like that it's like there's
got to be something right in Denmark
ruly just cared and loved
children and care and and you know what
that's what we should be focusing on
there are future they're us for sure you
know and uh I love this gen Z you know
they're they're so motivated they're
hopefully Gonna Save Us all but
um did you so the article that the so
the movie right the article that it was
made did you read the article that the
movie was no that that was that the guy
wrote that like was it like I know so
[__] heavy the guy wrote the Noah
harpser is a buddy of mine who wrote
them Noah and Micah who wrote that movie
right and so like well he was he's a
huge you guys should meet he wrote um do
you know him he wrote uh what was the
show with [__] uh Jeffrey Tambor and
he he Tran no [__] transparent
yes yes Sarah Silverman who I should
have asked instead of the [__]
woodpeck we call him the Woodpecker
Dennis yeah Vincent woodpecker because
he get he gets ideas and he just [__]
pecks he just [__] oh I like that
yeah nobody I mean I'm sure you hate it
but I don't know sometimes it would be
lost without it but it's just I feel
overwhelmed sometimes uh but anyway just
read the article it's crazy because the
bond that the you know Mr Rogers I guess
um really saved him like really saved
this journalist like really saved his
marriage saved you know and was really
there for him and um it's it's almost
like uh yeah it blew my mind but Noah
Noah is an incredible writer and just a
total Mr Rogers he's the one that kind
of turned turned me on to it and yeah
you were gonna ask me about Howard Stern
great interview and just hearing about
your early life and fighting and and
getting into trouble and then like
didn't you go to acting school in like
Moscow I mean it's just a very it's an
interesting trajectory and it it must
track like it's they see like the the
things that make up you seem to be at
odds and it's that's beautiful you know
I mean it's it's not I think I think it
makes me very much feel always like an
outsider in this which is something I'm
totally comfortable with and I've made
like real real peace with but I was
always that way as an as an artist yes
like I had this cousin who was like this
group but like I had no relation to that
it was all like you know yes and
fighting yeah yeah yeah and and that was
the only place I really found you know I
was like a pretty good ath I could like
play sports in college but I was never
as good as my you know like my friends
or my brother or like you know and being
wild and and doing the things nobody
else would do I'm gonna say you were
like teaching boxing
um in a Law and Order episode
uh yeah they're like kids fighting up on
a yeah yeah that was one of the first
things yeah no you were like a baby yeah
that was I'm a Law and Order head yeah
it was funny because uh Josh chamber she
ran my theater company man This
brilliant artist who died way too early
too he saw that and I guess I was so
nervous I was like scratchy like I I ran
a backyard wrestling thing right but I
also was a big steroid dealer so like
you know at Law and Order is it's like
you can either be the guy who lies or
you can be the guy that you get if you
if you're either the guy who tells the
truth to show you to the guy who's lying
or you're the guy's lying then you get
to come back and do another scene and
you reveal that you were lying right and
I was that guy and it was a big part you
know it was and dinofrio was on that and
he like sat down oh it was a Criminal
Intent Criminal Intent man and he told
me I did a good job that [__] [__] oh
that's incredible because I always heard
he was I had no tolerance for like not
actors that weren't excellent dude he
doesn't [__] around man he that guy
doesn't [__] around like he's so like
he's so if you are if you are an
antitheater assist to what we are trying
to do like director producer if you are
not part of the artistic Journey dude
you are the [__] enemy and he like
lets you know it's like it's great like
I saw him like just completely just like
crumple Marvel execs
but uh uh no I try to do [__] like that
but I'm way too nice I can't yeah but
anyway like but uh but yeah I used to
scratch myself because I was like so
nervous being it was the first time in
front of a camera but my friend Josh was
like you know that's like one of the big
side effects from like steroid use he
was like that was such an amazing
gesture and so yeah I said that was
pretty cool yeah I did some you know I
like yeah did some research on that I'm
a huge fan of like Peep World and I'm a
huge fit like I'm I'm uh you know like I
really I've never met anyone who's seen
that movie I thought that movie was
brilliant man and you're so good like I
just think like in so many of the so so
many in like the dramatic stuff like I
just think you're a brilliant actor and
I think that like uh I'm just like like
do you did you do you feel like an
outsider is it cheesy as [__] you do
right yeah yeah I think a lot of
comedians do like you know anytime
there's like some Hollywood thing
there's always like a little corner
where the comics find each other you
know and just kind of I think Island of
Misfit Toys ish but it's okay
[Music]
thank you for that announcement yeah
exactly
she talks right yeah
no way I didn't know that was a doggy
door is in the best I know that they
have you know like power over there
like
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign